ALIVERIES. SEEIN AND U  I FLL Y
APYI P $ HOURWIH
DEMANDTREASURYRE MIN IPI TOVIATE
TWO TOTHE EFF
TB PART THIS NEWL
BE PTI COMING
>> YOU CRUPT PAMERICA CHECKSMER
NUMBERS O T>>ND YANGNOW,USLY PT
MONEYO HANDSSASAL FOCUS
CAMP
EA S
THIS AS  HOW WOULD
YOU SEE THIS INICULARTU I AM THA
DURING THIS WE KNOW FINANCIAL ID
TO MONTHS.
I E
O YOU H S HOW MU W
I IN
PRU THINK IT NEEDSE HERE? IT NS
MINIMUM A T  TP
WE ARE .
E CDC ISSUEDAVOID
GAERIMAGINE WE GET MONEU KEEHAVI
BUSISS DON'T HAVEGINS TO OOR ST
OVER .YOU WAEE THAT'SLY THE RIG
MASSIVEBLEMS UP AND WN THE SCA
IDFYATRE
NOW AND DON'T HAVE A TO F
CIRCUMKING T
A BUSINESS OESTERD
SAIDY JUST MAKE IN
NORMAL TIMES THISSETBACK ISOINGY
NEVER REOPEN TIR DTHAT'S GOING D
THEE  B INYIS
NDS.THIS IS T SS
AS USUAL A TSI ORBUSINESSES,ANF
TOUCH MYAM.
WEREG TO HEND WE ALL NEEDTOLOGO
THE COUNTRY SGWHY HAVE TYEECHAN
HEALTHIER ANDROVES
OUR PUBLICRUUR EHATN THIS
TIME.
>>UAYOARFNESSESES AIRLINESRE PR
YO T PEOPLEIGY.
T
FDI
THEMESI AM NGGESTECRLINES A HHAI
SE BUT ISY TO FINAS UP.I  INDUS
FIRST AND ASTHROUGH  EHEIN BUSIS